after four years into temporary
locations
it's amazing to finally have our own
home
this building is where the spirits of
Carnegie Mellon University comes to life
it's a place guided by Andrew Carnegie's
words my heart is in the work
the building is big colorful and
interesting with plenty of spaces to
explore it gives us somewhere to study
and learn but it's also where we
socialize and meet up with our friends
the three-story atrium is spectacular
it's truly the heart of the building
it's where everything happens where we
eat have coffee study sleep talk with
the professors and have fun
our friends at the other universities in
education city come to Carnegie Mellon
because it's the hub of the campus the
building continues the collaborative
nature of our University where everyone
is
this new building is also a place for
Carnegie Mellon's oldest tradition hard
hard hard hard hard work the classrooms
lecture halls and loves are
state-of-the-art they enable us to learn
and grow and give us the foundation we
need to be successful and putter in
Pittsburgh or wherever our travels take
us
the coolest thing about the building
it's not just for current students and
professors it's a permanent home for
Carnegie Mellon somewhere we can always
come back to some work we can always
call
you